1. protego diabolica last up we have
protego diabolica the most advanced form
of the much more innocent Shield charm
protego in its most basic form protego
produces an invisible shield around its
Caster that reflects Bells but just a
few deviations away from this relatively
innocuous spell is protego diabolica the
most destructive spell in the entire
Wizarding World a spell that makes Avada
cadaver look like Bluebell Flames we
first witnessed protego diabolica on
screen in the crimes of Grindelwald
where Grindelwald casted inside of the
Lestrange Mausoleum protego diabolica
has a few levels to it but in its most
basic form the curse creates a ring of
protective black fire around the cast
air though it was blue in the film for
visual effects that instantly
incinerates any of the Caster's enemies
in this way proteko diabolica
demonstrates The Logical evolution of
protego which is also a defensive spell
a